you flash back you know roughly two
years ago we've got them censoring a
story that we all now know
is true
but don't take my word for it here's cbs
in salt lake city explaining exactly
what's going on with the hunter biden
laptop
leading up to the 2020 presidential
election the biden campaign hit a
roadblock a new york post report about a
laptop that landed at a delaware repair
shop apparently belonging to the
president's son hunter on that laptop a
trove of emails detailing hunter's
apparent business dealings including an
effort to connect his father then vice
president biden to a ukrainian energy
company where hunter sat on the board
but the effort to suppress the story
came almost immediately social media
outlets began limiting sharing of the
story on their platforms facebook
calling the move an effort to quote
reduce the spread of misinformation then
president-elect biden also waded into
the waters
from the fall about your son hunter for
russian disinfection yes yes yes but a
new york times report this week
confirming the authenticity of the
laptop now over a year removed from the
first report by the new york post the
effort to kill the original story is
under the spotlight here's a little
video compilation of media pundits and
talking heads
lying lying
and lie
biden secret emails a really fishy story
the post claimed that the emails were
found on a laptop computer that was
brought to a repair shop in delaware in
the spring of 2019. the fbi is now
investigating whether those alleged
underbide emails are actually connected
to a larger foreign intelligence
operation they may be related to a
foreign intelligence operation foreign
intelligence operation foreign
intelligence foreign intelligence
foreign intelligence operation for all
we know these emails are made up the
information found on the laptop may be
part of a russian disinformation
campaign part of a russian
disinformation uh effort described by
many intelligence experts as having
hallmarks all the hallmarks rather all
the hallmarks of a russian or russian
russian disinformation russian
disinformation disinformation campaign
this is a classic example of the
right-wing media machine
i like the lady in the mask the most you
know like you're on television not
sitting near anyone are you clowns
anyway you can really see how lies just
get laundered through the system right
you can just see it how then all of
these people who are supposed to be
journalists who are supposed to be the
fourth estate they're supposed to be
protecting us from the powers that be
right they're supposed to be making sure
that we
the citizens are informed properly about
the goings-on of the people that are in
charge but they actually do the complete
reverse they do the complete reverse i
mean brian stelter okay you got busted
man you're busted are you going to have
your maya culpa and say boy i really
went in all on this scandal and it turns
out everything that i reported on about
trump and russia and the laptop being
fake and everybody else ah
i'm an idiot i'm either an idiot i'm
either a willful idiot because it felt
it fit the narrative that i liked or i'm
a propagandist like pick one potato uh
here's video of joe biden right before
the election and he's very indignant
that it's all nonsense this whole thing
we showed you this one the other day too
but i'm building a case here like a
prosecutor people
so what about the americans who really
today only want me to ask you about
hunter biden's laptop how are you going
to get them
to see
that you are fighting for them when
they're
here there's nothing to any of that
nothing to that it's all a smear
every major outfit every serious
investigator has pointed out
that this is a smear
this is classic trump we have four days
left and all of a sudden there's a
laptop and you may recall there's also
talk about
four months before there was a similar
thing that somebody had allegedly
there's overwhelming evidence that from
the intelligence community that the
russians are engaged i mean look this is
my son's an honorable man and all the
investigations that were done around the
issue of what was going on in ukraine if
you notice
every one of the major people who worked
for trump
during the impeachment went under oath
and under oath said biden did his job
no wall was providing this biden did his
job hunter biden broke no laws that was
the testimony
their testimony from republicans and
intelligence community people
i mean i just don't even know what
planet that guy is on everything he said
there is a lie every single thing he
said there his son is an honorable man
even he's a crack addict no offense to
crack addicts um but he said every major
outlet this is how you see the the lies
get laundered he knows that the major
outlets are working for him so when they
say hey is the laptop really says well
every major outlet says it isn't real
yes because the major outlets either
cover
uh for you or lie about it or ignore the
story entirely then he also says every
serious investigator what he's referring
to there is the 50
intelligence officials who all said this
was russian misinformation and now it
turns out to be true because the whole
freaking swamp lives to protect the
swamp
i don't mean to be a dick about it it
just is i'm not even it just is it just
is and you really have to understand
that and then of course he calls it
classic trump it's classic trump to make
up all of this stuff if by classic trump
he means oh somebody actually telling
the truth somehow pushing out some level
of truth through all of this insanity
then i guess that is classic trump